darling aren't you happy we moved into  this decrepit Victorian Mansion yeah  this is a wonderful location to raise a  family by the way where does that door  lead to yeah I tried opening it but  couldn't find the key so it's it's it  could be anything we have so many uh  other things to do I mean this seems  relatively urgent  uh yeah I'll Circle back to it so you're  okay with us uh just not having access  to a section of our house that we own uh  and I'll get back to it okay something's  like moaning back there oh yeah well  it just said murder valid valid point  but we'll Circle back to it I don't  think I can live here anymore I need to  divorce you  we will also Circle back to it I want  full legal custody of our kids I'll just  circle back to that I'm scared